des couleurs des odeurs des saveurs les
herbes et épices nous font voyager sans
se déplacer
au québec il n'y a pas si longtemps
l'offre était plutôt limité
c'était ses seins moi ce que je viens de
cette fois c'était de l'ail des oignons
persil basilic l'organe au aujourd'hui
les supermarchés nous offre des
centaines de choix ces nouveaux qu'on
avait autant puisque les coûts et les
préférences des consommateurs se sont
raffinées avec le tard on a acheté 25 kg
de paprika fumé
aujourd'hui on agite suppose qu'à tonnes
c'est impressionnant mais devant tous
ses choix le consommateur peut se sentir
déroutés lorsque vous allez à la saq
vous fait pas ouvrir les bouteilles de
vin y goûter si c'est celui là vous avez
envie d'acheter la même façon on peut
pas ouvrir les emballages des pistes
pour savoir si les pisse compliment est
à la hauteur de la mémé ps2 vendues chez
mccormick ou chez vision vous devez
faire confiance à ce qu'on appelle les
indices extrinsèque de qualité et ça
c'est d'abord et avant tout le prix
également l'emballage et la marque
il faut faire preuve d'imagination pour
se démarquer et compétitionner avec des
géants comme économique
à qui appartient au cycle au bar les
épices d'ions ont donc décidé de
présenter leurs produits
dans des petits contenants de plastique
empilables notre continent nous offre 22
ans qu'on vend des épices aideront à
améliorer encore le concept énormément
au niveau de la halle à lui le lac peut
rentrer à l'intérieur
les soeurs en vrac elles ont plutôt opté
pour des contenants métalliques et un
positionnement différent en épicerie un
moment donné on essayait d'avoir de
l'espace de tablettes qui voulaient pas
nous en donnait donc on s'est dit
comment est ce qu'on veut pas lier à se
pisser en fabriquant un rack puis en
leur disant mais voici votre ac
voici votre concept avez vous deviez par
deux pieds puis mettez-les l'opsis avant
qu'on va leur prendre le type de
contenant a une influence sur le prix
les épices en bouteilles sont vendues
plus chères que celles vendues dans un
sachet de plastique peu plus pouvoir la
praticité z un emballage qui va se tenir
tout seul et qui collera pas dans votre
garde manger
on espère que vous allez associés la
qualité du produit à la qualité de
l'emballage et serait prêt à payer plus
cher en conséquence mais est-ce que les
épices plus cher nous en donne plus pour
notre argent
l'épicerie a demandé à claudine tac
d'une spécialiste des peas et à deux
chefs marian bédard et jonathan garnier
de se prononcer sur la qualité d'une
quarantaine de pistes moulu et d'herbes
séchées
parmi les plus populaires des moins cher
au plus cher notre panel goutta cinq
échantillons de cumin dont les prix
varient de 3 à 16 dollars 200 g
[Musique]
les nids sont hamad mais les mousses et
super super court en bouche
les écarts de prix du basilic sont
encore plus spectaculaire passant de 3 à
137 $ le sens gratte les herbes à fort
teneur en eau une fois séchés ou peu
d'intérêt ils perdent énormément de leur
intensité
je suis triste pour nous c'est triste ça
sans rien quand paris a aussi goûté
cannes l ail lauriers et poivre moulu
au final malgré les écarts de prix notre
panel considère qu'il n'y a pas de
grands écarts de goût entre les produits
league ou de à l'autre à peu près pas
distinctif les épices moulues ou séchés
perdent beaucoup de leur saveur et sont
plus sensibles à la chaleur la lumière
et à l'humidité que les épices entières
c'est pour ça que malheureusement les
sacs transparents les bouteilles
transparentes super joli ça va très bien
pour les ranger sur les tablettes et
tout est d'une certaine façon on voit le
produit c'est un avantage mais comme ces
photosensible l'avantagent devient un
inconvénient et nomme impôts c'est de
savoir depuis quand les peas a été
moulues d'autant plus que la plupart des
distributeurs font affaire avec des
importateurs qui avons à faire avec de
petits producteurs dans des pays
lointains
pour maximiser le goût beaucoup de
connaisseurs préfèrent acheter les pisse
entière si vous avez le choix vous
achetez maulus entière entier oui oui
pour être capable de prendre un moulin
pingu dans la maison c'est sûr que plus
de goût avec le lancier comme soit main
[Musique]
acheté les puissants tiers où l'herbe
fraîche vous protégera de certaines
fraudes alimentaires selon l'agencé
canadienne d'inspection des aliments
30% des épées sur le marché sont non
conformes soit pour des raisons
d'étiquetage de salubrité ou encore
d'authenticité
par exemple dans certains poivre moulu
on a retrouvé des morceaux de branche ou
de feuilles broyées
quand vous achetez une graine entière
vous savez ça en est une donc je ne peux
pas être dit chose ça peut être un
mélange ça peut pas être ajoutées avec
plein de produits coupés avec avec de la
poudre de bris autre avantage et les
puissants tiers se conservera plus
longtemps que les pistes moulu et parce
que si tu fait l'achat de sa chaîne des
peas qui gros comme ça et que tu veux
pas le consommer avant les trois
prochaines années
moi je dis que tu en as besoin
vos caniche et on boit parce qu'au fond
on utilise pour